[Music]
good evening i'm nicholas paul bryce
wits director of development here at the
long now foundation and as always i want
to thank you for joining us tonight by a
quick show of applause how many of you
out there tonight
are stainless steel card-carrying
members of the long now foundation
that's that's incredible
our membership program is about to clear
10,000 members across more than 60
countries and that membership really has
become the foundation of our foundation
your regular support is a significant
fraction of our overall operating budget
every single year and it allows us to do
what we do so in a very real way we
couldn't do that without you so thank
you the other significant fraction of
our operating budget comes from our
annual fundraising campaign at the end
of every single year like many nonprofit
organizations the long now foundation
raises an astounding percentage of our
operating budget between now and the end
of the year and this this regular season
allottee means that for 10 months out of
the year we get to do a lot of giving we
get to give away ideas and conversations
and content and public space and for two
months out of the year we get to ask you
to help us do more of that
so this year if you're interested and if
you're able to help us do more long-term
thinking in the world I'd like to invite
you to either make a special
tax-deductible donation or upgrade your
membership level or claim one of those
bottles of exclusive spirits in the
ceiling at the interval or if you'd like
you can also reserve one of these some
of you may have seen this object before
but this is the equation of time cam and
it's a vital component of the 10,000
year clock this unique shape is a
physical instantiation of a math
equation that accounts for the dynamic
motion of our home planet across the
next 10 millennia you can almost think
of it as the heart of the clock
and a few years ago we manufactured a
limited edition of these and I'm as part
of our annual fundraising campaign today
I'm excited to announce that we've just
launched a brand new custom machined
edition of the equation of time cam that
was manufactured in the exact same clock
shop that did a lot of the clock parts
and so if you want to learn more about
this piece you can visit long now org
slash artifacts check out this and some
of our other artifacts and of course you
didn't come here tonight to hear me talk
about fundraising campaigns and clock
parts so without any further ado I'd
like to introduce our long-short as some
of you know we always kind of set the
tone for the evening with a brief video
and tonight's video is in a way about
networks thank you so much
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's and I am Stewart Brand long now
that's a tiny sample of what passenger
patrons used to do and if all goes well
we'll do again only they did it 60 miles
an hour a straight line from one place
to another and then all that swarming
when they landed by the way when further
note on that beautiful equation of time
cam that's made out of bronze the
donation that gets it is $2,500 and
since the unit cost on those beautifully
crafted things is about $900 it's a
pretty good deal the conceit of long now
foundation is that we're sort of in the
midst of a 20,000 year story of
civilization dating back to the first
towns and agriculture and dating forward
to what remains to be seen and what
remains to be done and in consequence
we're sort of in love with historians
who are all about telling the long story
in ever new ways and civilizations story
is basically a story of argument swarms
of arguments and these arguments get
played out and firms often of power
there's an argument about economic power
as arguments about political power
arguments about military power and from
time to time arguments about the whole
mode that power gets played out in and
that's what we hear about tonight from
historian Niall Ferguson
[Music]
thank you very much indeed Stuart it's a
great pleasure to be here tonight thank
you for braving the air to join us you
may have heard it announced today that
the annual White House Correspondents
Dinner will no longer feature a comedian
but a historian which made me think that
perhaps history was the new comedy I do
not intend to give you stand up tonight
let me disillusion you what I want to do
is talk about networks and power I'll be
talking quite a bit about what's in my
most recent book the square and the
tower but I'll also be trying to go a
little further than I did in that book
thinking about what we need to do if we
are to manage what has been created the
extraordinary giant online social
networks made in Northern California in
our time the law now I guess is an
attempt to situate the present and I
have always admired what Stuart and his
colleagues have done in helping us to
understand our position in a continuum
of human history over thousands of years
but the corollary of the long now is the
short then and the short then is a
phrase that hit me as I was hurtling up
to 80 this evening what I want to convey
to you is how near the past is and how
relevant it is to the problems that we
confront today and that some of the
things that we know about events 500
year
ago can illuminate our long now if you
want to get a handle on that
relationship between networks and
hierarchies that central to the square
and the tower jota's Sienna one of the
most beautiful towns in all of Italy and
look at the extraordinary juxtaposition
in the center of Siena of the Piazza del
Campo the square one of the most
beautiful squares in all of Italy and
the Torre del mangia which casts a long
shadow over is the square is where the
people of Siena networks where they hang
out chat informally exchanged whether in
a marketplace or even in a horse race
between the local districts the tower
was part of the Palazzo publico where
the government of the Republic of Siena
was located and one of the ideas I want
to convey to you tonight is that we
today also live our lives partly in a
square partly in the realm of social
networks but also partly in the realm of
hierarchies I'm a kind of networks
person I've always hated hierarchies I
would have been terrible in the military
even academic structures of governance
slightly unnerved me I became an
academic because it seemed to me that
universities were the least hierarchical
of organizations and so I gonna
naturally prefer to be in the horizontal
realm of the Town Square but I can't
escape the hierarchies of universities
and of governments whether we like it or
not we're all situated partly in the
square and partly in the term
now it's a cliche of our time but like
many cliches it's true that the world
has never been as networked as it is
today and that is I think the case
certainly when you look at the way the
network platforms Amazon Google Facebook
Twitter the way those companies have
built giant online social networks
there's never been anything quite like
that before today's networks are very
large and they're fast they operate much
more rapidly than previous networks
could because of Technology I quite like
this visualization of the Facebook
network put your hand up if you're on
Facebook go on don't pretend you're not
so to an extraordinary extent mankind is
on Facebook two point two seven billion
regular users and this map tries to plot
every city pair with what's called a
Great Circle Line and the transparency
of each of these great circle lines is
determined by the number of friend pairs
in the cities hence the extraordinary
brightness of North America where
Facebook originated and the
extraordinary darkness of the People's
Republic of China where it's still not
admitted we were told and I think most
of us believed it that if everybody was
connected then everything would be
awesome we are creating a world where
anyone anywhere may express his or her
beliefs no matter how singular without
fear of being coerced into silence or
conformity John Perry Barlow the late
lamented epitomized the libertarian
spirit of the the early internet and the
idea that if we're all connected it will
be awesome has persisted in much that
mark
Zuckerberg has said as Facebook has
grown this was him speaking at the
Harvard commencement last year all
people want to connect the great arc of
human history bends towards people
coming together in ever greater numbers
to achieve things we couldn't on our own
that was the promise I think most of us
believed it and then came 2016 the annus
horribilis of the liberal internet
political events first in Britain in
June of 2016 then in the United States
in the member November of 2016
km as a huge shock because it turned out
that the network platforms that the
tools that had been created by Silicon
Valley could be used for purposes that
were certainly far from utopian I got to
know Evan Williams recently he's a
really nice guy very impressive but he
said something last year that went to
the heart of the matter I thought once
everybody could speak freely and
exchange information and ideas
the world is automatically going to be a
better place I was wrong about that and
I think most of us were wrong about that
and I think we all need to say to
ourselves what Homer Simpson often says
to himself well though the square in the
tower is is about why it all went a bit
wrong and in particular why both
networks science and history should have
made as much more wary of the promise of
a massively insecure nectars planet now
I say Network Science and History
because part of what writing the book
helped me do as an historian
was to learn much more about network
science than I had known before a lot of
my career had been spent writing about
networks partly because I'm
temperamentally drawn to them as I said
before I always found government
archives slightly stuffy places but
private papers their archives of
companies that always appeal to be more
but I used the word the word Network
very casually like most people do I'm
going out networking tonight I hadn't
really understood the six great laws of
network science and it was when I
started to read Network scientists work
like say laszlo barabasi 'he's amazing
book linked or i started to read
Nicholas Christakis his work on social
networks I suddenly realized this
applies to history and if we only think
about history using these tools we'll
we'll see it through completely fresh
eyes once you understand the basic
conceptual framework everything the
present the past and potentially the
futures that we confront looks different
if I could graph the social network of
you all as they say in Texas if I could
just know a little bit maybe a lot about
you all if I could get Mark Zuckerberg
to give me all your data which he he
used to do but it's got a little tougher
then I could graph the network to me you
just be nodes and the relationships
between you would just be edges and what
would be fascinating would be that this
would not be a lattice in which each
node had the same number of edges as the
rest no social network was like that
there would be clusters some of you are
quite closely connected there's a little
inner circle of long now lifers
and then then there would be the network
isolate the person who came in here by
mistake
thinking it was jazz doesn't know
anybody here doesn't know who the hell I
am bit too embarrassed to get up and go
yet the hub of this network would be
Stewart Stewart has the highest
betweenness centrality because for any
two nodes in this network to connect the
quickest way is almost certainly through
Stewart Brand as I delved into this way
of thinking about society and the
connections between people It was as if
scales fell from my eyes and I began to
see past work that I'd done in a
completely different light so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to tell you the
six great truths about networks
borrowing from the work of network
scientists and then I'm going to do the
big analogy because if you want to get
from the the long now to the short then
what you need is a big analogy that's
the history piece and then in the fourth
quarter I'm going to as you're all
beginning to nod off or check your
devices I'm very i've got eagle eyes for
device checkers our cold call anybody I
see on Facebook in the final quarter I'm
going to tell you what this implies for
our present predicament and what we need
to do that's not in the book so you'll
be in a unique position birds of a
feather flock together okay if we did
the social network if we graph the
network in here it'd be quite
interesting if we found what often turns
out to be true of social networks that
there were two rather distinct clusters
there's a great illustration of this
point in a recent paper by brady in' and
company which shows the extraordinary
polarization of political twitter and
can see here a graph that depicts
retweet activity on political issues of
American Twitter users liberals retweet
liberals and conservatives retweet
conservatives and there's hardly any
retweet activity across the great
political divide we used to call it the
political center we now call it the
killing zone and for every moral or
emotive word you use in a tweet it is
20% more likely to be retweeted so if
you're wondering why there's so much
strong language on Twitter people have
figured that out this is not a new
insight sociologists working in the
1970s knew that there was something
called homophily they knew it when they
studied the networks of friendships in
American high schools that was supposed
to be racially integrated but weren't
despite all the efforts of policymakers
posts the civil rights movement
self-segregation was going on in these
high schools and self-segregation goes
on on the giant online social networks
of our time so homophily is the first
law and and it should not have surprised
us that creating giant online social
networks would in fact create not one
happy global community all sharing cat
videos but this second insight from
network science it's a small world
because week tires are strong the straws
on the work of eminent sociologists like
Milgram and Granovetter and the basic
insight is that we all have our close
circle of family and friends but the
reason that there are six degrees of
separation which started out as a short
story and then turned out in Stanley
Milgram's work to be true is that our
clusters of friends and family are all
connected by the the loose casual
acquaintance
that we have they act as bridges or
connectors to other people's clusters of
friends and family and Milgram showed in
a famous paper from 1967 these are the
cheesy graphics from the paper it was
the sixties after all but if you sent
chain letters from random people in the
Midwest to aid that were designed to get
to a particular individual in New
England that none of them knew it took
six or seven steps for the letter to get
there this was the first demonstration
of the small world principle that there
are roughly six degrees of separation
between any two randomly selected human
beings
the third insight for network size is
that stuff goes viral not just because
of its content I know you think that
something goes viral the cat video that
goes viral goes viral because it's a
cool video but it's not just that it's
not just the inherent content that
matters it is the structure of the
network that the cat video attacks that
matters this is true in the study of
epidemic disease and it's true in the
study of cultural memes so that's the
third key point to bear in mind network
structure determines a lot if you attack
the network at the right point if we
give the meme to Stewart of the awesome
cat video it is much more likely to go
viral than if we give it to the jazz fan
who's too polite to leave it's all about
where you enter the network and what the
network structure is like if there is a
node with high betweenness centrality
that's that's crucial to why things go
viral fourth point this is my attempt to
distill all of Network science into six
things I could remember in talks
networks never sleep networks are
complex adaptive systems with emergent
properties and phase transitions and
that's why the bird video at the
beginning was so great because that's a
perfect illustration of what we mean by
emergent properties what we mean by a
complex system if only human beings were
as good networking as birds and we're
always colliding into one another but
we're human beings flying our around up
there above that field after 10 minutes
they would have formed two hostile
clusters of conservative and liberal
birds and have been flying at one
another so this is another important
point to remember there are lots of
network graphs in this talk and in my
book but they're just snapshots of
things that are constantly in flux and
because they are truly complex adaptive
systems they don't behave in predictable
ways weird stuff can happen a network
can go from being highly distributed and
decentralized to being highly
centralized in a matter of days example
the great revolutions of modern times as
I try to show in the book the Bolshevik
Revolution looked like a massive
distributed network sweeping across the
Russian Empire with minimal coordination
Lenin's message just went viral but
within a few years of the Bolshevik
seizure of power the Bolshevik network
had gone from being decentralized to
being highly centralized a dictatorship
of the proletariat in fact the
dictatorship by the party elite talking
of Bolshevism and I just made that segue
up completely on the spur of the moment
um one of the best examples of the the
attack syndrome the fact that networks
attack networks was the attack by the
Soviet communist regime on the elite
intellectual networks of my country of
origin the United Kingdom this is one of
my favorite stories in the
by the way the book is full of stories
it's it's actually designed to be read
by people with attention deficit
disorder I divided it up into 60 6-0
short chapters and you don't need to
read them all or even read them in the
right order it's it's designed for
people who keep checking their email
this is one of my favorite of the
stories it's the story of the Cambridge
spies the biggest success to date
including recent events of Russian
espionage what did they do they hacked
an elite network the Apostles the most
elite of all the intellectual societies
at the very pinnacle of Cambridge
University's social life but cleverest
of the clever the self-perpetuating
elite that still exists today and the
Apostles were hacked by Soviet operative
named Arnold Deutsch who managed to
recruit three of its members to the
Communist Party knowing that as members
of the Apostles they would be highly
likely to attain high positions in the
British establishment which they did
including high high positions in British
military intelligence networks attack
networks and it takes a network to
defeat a network a line I got from
General Stanley McChrystal 'he's book
about his time in Iraq I'm saving the
sixth law of networks for just a little
bit later but now the big analogy and
this is my favorite part because this is
the history part so what is it like
that's the question you should always be
asking about the present the hell is
this like and every day in every edition
of the New York Times somebody will tell
you that it's the 1930s and then in the
Washington Post somebody will tell you
that it's the 1970s
but I'm here to tell you that all these
analogies with the mid 20th century are
of no use at all because the structure
of the public sphere has been changed so
much by the internet that it's nothing
like the mid 20th century our time our
time most closely resembles the period
after the late 15th century when the
printing press are you laugh sir that's
what I like to hear incredulity because
it's a typical American response that
anything that happened before the United
States is irrelevant so the history of
the United States you're wrong
you so wrong let me show you how wrong
you are nothing has happened like the
impacts of the personal computer and the
internet since the advent of the
printing press and here's the proof if
you look at the impact of these two
technologies and there's a wonderful
paper by a guy named dick Moore in
London who does this it's incredibly
similar the effect of the technological
innovation is drastically fruit to
reduce the cost of producing content and
drastically to increase the volume of
content these two graphs are the same
one for the printed book the other for
the personal computer what's the
difference the timescale history today
happens 10 times faster than it did at
the time of the printing press but
that's the only significant difference
except for one more I'll come to you so
the better analogy for thinking about
our time is not 1930s it's not what
again that's all very interesting but we
live in a different time we live at a
time of massive technological disruption
of the public sphere and most of us
underestimated especially those of us
who cling to old ways of getting
information like newspapers made of
we underestimate the extent to which our
time is a time of communications
revolution as dramatic as the time of
the Reformation oh yes this is a scary
analogy it is not a funny analogy sir it
is a bloody terrifying analogy because
when they introduced the printing press
into Europe everything was going to be
awesome
Martin Luther for it was he just 501
years ago said if everybody can read the
Bible on a printed version of the text
in their own language everything will be
awesome
we didn't quite use that that word what
it actually said was will achieve the
priesthood of all believers the Bible
speaks off not quite what happened what
happened was that yeah Martin Luther's
sermons were rapidly spread through her
all of Europe thanks to rapid production
by printing presses but so were books
like the malleus Maleficarum which
argued that witches live amongst us and
have to be burnt at the stake that book
the malleus Maleficarum the hammer of
wickedness was one of the bestsellers of
the 16th and 17th century that's a good
example of fake news and it's a good
example of something going viral that is
a good deal more harmful than a cat
video you know how it is that people
always wanted to tear down statues these
days have you noticed that and rename
things iconoclasm is a typical product
of a disruption of the public sphere
suddenly we must face the icons of the
previous era that happened in the period
of the Reformation too as in this
illustration of a church getting a full
Protestant makeover in Antwerp and 1566
polarization
in the sixteenth and seventeenth-century
escalated rapidly from verbal violence
you're a heretic no you're a heretic no
you are a heretic into actual violence
the threshold between verbal violence
and actual violence is a very fragile
fence and they crushed it and they spent
a hundred and thirty years crossing it
the Wars of Religion that persisted from
the peasants revolt that followed
Luther's Reformation all the way to the
end of the 30 Years War in 1648 I
sometimes think we're living through a
secular Reformation it's not religion
but political ideology but it takes a
similar form there's a whole range of
different things that we now categorize
as hate speech well in the 16th and 17th
century you didn't say hate speech you
said blasphemy what we are experiencing
though it hasn't yet escalated to the
levels of religious warfare could
because there's no obvious reason why
the polarization process that I've
described to you should stop
it's always important to think ahead to
what's true or askew so obviously there
are all kinds of differences between my
short Lenin and the long now one of them
I've mentioned already
everything happens 10 times faster today
that's good news they had a hundred and
thirty years of religious conflict we
should get it down to thirteen they had
the thirty years war it'll only be three
for us there's another so here's a
really interesting thought that I had
right in the book after the printing
press was invented amazingly it stayed a
distributed network and people didn't
sell ads on most of what was printed
very few ads on Luther's sermons you'll
find and that's the big difference
between then and now we thought that the
internet was going to remain a
decentralized thing Tim berners-lee's
vision of the World Wide Web was just
like the birds flying around nobody's in
charge everybody's just flying together
whoo and then it turned out that unlike
the printing press you could centralize
the internet you could centralize the
software you could centralize ecommerce
you could centralize social networking
you could decentralize digital media the
internet was supposed to assure in this
wonderful era when we were all going to
be netizens do you remember that seems
like another world doesn't it we're
going to all speak truth to power on our
personal blogs all all at once it's
gonna be awesome and then the best blog
would be netizen of the year seems like
a hundred years ago that we believed
that stuff instead what happened with
amazing speed was the a relatively small
number of near monopoly companies
took over the internet to go over the
World Wide Web and they created
hierarchical structures
I love these org charts because they're
authentically funny and whoever did this
cartoon is really cool because they kept
they have a sort of grain of truth in
each case and anybody whose works for
one of these companies will I think
attest to that but the point is that
what we thought was going to be a
decentralized distributed awesome cool
network where would just be adding nodes
and and blogging with amazing speed
became hierarchical because remember
phase transitions emergent property it's
a complex system it was never gonna stay
the way Tim designed it sorry Tim two
consequences of the advent of the
network platforms the return of monopoly
capitalism my good friend Peter Thiel
explaining why monopolies are awesome in
his book zero to one which is a huge
bestseller not least in China I'll come
to China in a minute Scott Galloway's
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse each one
controlling one of your vital organs
Google as your brain Facebook's your
heart
Amazon's your gut will you do the
consumption and I won't say exactly what
Apple is except that phones are status
symbols I suppose the advent of monopoly
capitalism is kind of mind-blowing
enough and certainly not something that
many people predicted if any even more
important is what the network platforms
have done to democracy and that's really
what I want to focus on with the
remaining time I have if you were paying
attention to the importance of social
media during the 2016 election you
spotted that Donald Trump's probability
of beating Hillary Clinton was way
higher than all the political scientists
and pundits were saying who were using
polling data and models of the pre
social media political system he
dominated her
he dominated her on Facebook he
dominated her on Twitter he actually
dominated her also on Google search and
just eight years before these platforms
had been marginal in their importance to
understand what was going to happen in
November 10 2016 you have to see that
this had happened
Brad Pascal who was Trump's digital
director put it very nicely these social
platforms are all invented by very
liberal people on the west and east
coast and we figure out how to use it to
push conservative values I don't think
they thought that would ever happen
The Economist nearly got it rights
social medias threat to democracy no no
there's nothing undemocratic about
populist winning elections the real
threat was to liberalism the real threat
was to to be precise the political
middle-ground
that was the thing that was threatened
we now know and with every week we know
more that the Russians used Facebook and
Twitter to disseminate fake news and
extreme views my favorite meme of
Russian origin is the one on the bottom
right there Satan if I win Clinton wins
Jesus not if I can help it press like to
help Jesus win gotta hand it to Eve an
instant Petersburg that is pretty smart
[ __ ] but here are a couple of
interesting things number one it turns
out that liberals were more likely to
retweet Russian content than
conservatives I guess this was can you
believe the crap these conservatives say
and the other thing is that Russian
content was probably around 1% of all
the political content on social media
during the 2016 election campaign that's
not a lot
most of the content was homegrown
now you can take your choice depending
on how you like to think about the
historical process in a very close
election everything can be regarded as
the critical variable from the weather
to the Russians to the fact that Hillary
Clinton didn't go to Wisconsin but I
want to suggest that the most plausible
counterfactual for 2016 is that if it
had not been for the network platforms
Donald Trump could not have won if you
imagine the election without facebook
without Twitter without YouTube let's
not forget it would have been very hard
for the Trump campaign to overcome its
financial disadvantage the Facebook
advertising is the killer app of modern
politics because it's targeted precision
targeted and cheap this is the key
inside of 2016 meanwhile on the other
side of the world things go very
differently China builds a far wall
around its own Internet and essentially
keeps the Western the US companies out
we laugh and say that's like trying to
nail jello to a wall as Bill Clinton
famously put it and the Chinese said
watch as nail jello to the wall
watch as also build the only tech
companies in the world that can rival
yours which they proceeded to do Baidu
Alibaba $0.10 are the only rivals in the
world to the big Internet companies we
sometimes refer to by the acronym Fang
and another amazing thing not only did
the Chinese match Silicon Valley in some
domains they do better than Silicon
Valley like in mobile payments and in
processing speed the next time you're in
China if you haven't been for a while
you'll notice that ever
pays for things with their phones and
they laugh at you when you take out your
credit card that's because they have
pulled ahead in FinTech and the ability
that the big Chinese tech companies have
to process vast numbers of transactions
not only exploiting the scale of the
Chinese market but increasingly
expanding abroad into other emerging
markets also gives them an advantage in
the artificial intelligence arms race
unlike here in China the square in the
tower at least appear to be in harmony
Jack Ma last year before he got his
marching orders from Xi Jinping said at
a Communist Party conference the
political and legal system of the future
is inseparable from Big Data bad guys
won't even be able to walk into the
square I've got a little kind of cold
shivery feeling in my spine when I read
that quotation first I thought excellent
he used the word square this will help
my book and then I thought wait what
does he mean by the square oh yeah in
China there's only one square this was a
coded reference to the way in which AI
big data can be used to prevent their
ever being another 1989 in Tiananmen
Square there are three models three ways
of dealing with the problems that we've
created with technology the Chinese
model is clear the network platforms of
China will be subordinated to the wishes
of the party and if necessary if
possible a system of social credit will
be built on the basis of the individual
citizens data that you might think of as
totality anism 2.0 1984 but with a
portable telly screen that you volunteer
to be under surveillance by the European
approach is different the Europeans have
no technology companies worth talking
about all they can do is tax regulate
and find the American
companies and that is what they're
proceeding to do George Soros at Davos
earlier this year said it's only a
matter of time before the global
dominance of the US IT monopolies is
broken
EU competition a competition
commissioner vest Argo will be their
nemesis but what happens here what
happens in the United States
where these companies were born where
the internet was created that's not
clear all I think I can say with any
confidence is that there will be a
struggle between the tower and the
square and it began with this little
exchange on social media last year and
it is escalating to a remarkable extent
this year mainly because conservatives
have come to believe that they are going
to be discriminated against by the
network platforms because they are all
run by liberals and it will never be
2016 again in my conceptual framework
this is the old battle between the
square and the tower if you think of
Silicon Valley as the square and Trump
Tower is the tower but the difference is
that and this is another parallel with
the sixteenth and seventeenth-century
outside actors are just free to join in
the whole saga of the caravan remember
the caravan to a remarkable extent
stories about the caravan of would be
illegal immigrants stroke asylum seekers
marching towards the US border intent on
deciding the outcome of the midterms
that whole story was generated on
Facebook groups groups which Turner and
close inspection to
foreign administrators if you think
things have been fixed at Facebook or
fixed at YouTube you've drunk the
kool-aid again let me conclude because
I've gone on long enough what can we
learn from my big analogy what can that
short then that very near 16th and 17th
century experience of polarization
conflict fake news driven by a
technological disruption what can it
teach us about today well the answer is
we need a cyber Westphalia we need to
end our 30 Years War preferably before
it begins
in 1648 Europeans finally drew a line
under a hundred and thirty years of
religious conflict it was done with
complex to complex treaties which
defined what we now think of today as
the sovereignty of states well I want to
suggest to you this evening that we need
to get there preferably without the
intervening strife this is my last slide
but it's got a lot of content it's
actually a single slide digesting a
twenty thousand word paper that was
published last week by the Hoover
Institution where I work in title what
is to be done and in that paper which is
available free on the Hoover website I
try to address what we do and I go
through the six ideas that I can out
there and I reject two and a half of
them I don't think it makes any
difference whether there is net
neutrality or not that's just about the
balance of power
profit between internet service
providers and network platforms it
doesn't change a thing I don't think
that antitrust legislation can be
resuscitated
as Tim Wu and others believe and that
these companies can be broken up at
least I don't think it can be done fast
enough given the strong bias of the US
courts against the old version the
Brandeis version of antitrust and in
favor of the post 1960s Bork version I
think it's not a viable project in any
case there are natural monopolies in the
realm of networks and this will be I
think a blind alley there needs to be
regulation more than there has been and
more effective regulation than there has
been but we mustn't make the mistake of
thinking oh there utilities we should
regulate them the way we regulated the
railroads what I argue in this paper is
for three distinct steps the first is to
get rid of the strange now anachronistic
rule that exempts the network platforms
from liability for the content that they
carry on their platforms this goes back
to the mid-1990s when most of these
companies didn't exist and now makes no
sense when they're the biggest companies
in the world section 230 makes no sense
when essentially these are the biggest
content publishers in history 80% of
Americans most of the people in this
room get their news via referral from
either Google or Facebook the pretense
that they're just tech companies that
the liability for the content belongs
with the original traditional media
producer or the user who posted them the
comment that seems to me an anachronism
but even as we expose the network
platforms to liability for the content
that they produce or publish we must
ensure
that they don't become the sensors of
our public sphere and that is the
tendency that we currently see partly
under european pressure partly because
of european regulation more and more is
being done in the name of community
standards it's a slippery slope if we
leave the network platforms to decide
what is hate speech and what is not what
should appear in the rankings and what
should not that is too much power for
private corporations to wield far too
much and that's why I make another
proposal which that is to say that they
should uphold the First Amendment
because they have become the public
sphere
and that's a controversial proposal but
I think it's necessary if we are to
avoid the fate of a kind of privatized
China in which content is censored by
Facebook and Google on our behalf in
deference to increasingly restrictive
notions of what is hate speech last but
not least and this is the most
Westphalian part of it we need urgently
an International Convention on cyber war
we've had such conventions before on
everything from piracy to biological
weapons the great powers represented
today by the five permanent members of
the UN Security Council need to
recognize that this process of constant
violation of one another sovereignty
which is the essence of what happened in
2016 is dangerous to all of them now
there's a problem with that which is to
get Russia to stop behaving like a rogue
regime on alternate days and a great
power on the other days but one lesson
of the 17th century is that that can be
done the habit of violating sovereignty
which has been re-established in our
time can be broken that is what they
achieved
in Westphalia in 1648 I hope I persuaded
you that history plus network science
provide a useful way to think about our
contemporary problems I hope I've
persuaded you sir that the analogy is
not a frivolous one but actually a
deadly serious one and now all I need to
do is urge you to buy the book remember
you don't need to read it just need to
own it
thank you for paying attention to me an
invite Stuart brand to come and join me
up on the stage thanks very much
[Applause]
he's got a lot of questions in his hand
it's quite worrying that's a dozen form
of applause when you get lots of
questions sometimes we don't Kevin
Kelley who manages the questions managed
for his on top that's his privilege it's
a hierarchy really it looks like a
network and he's asking if the internet
founders who are probably most of them
still alive had known history had
studied with you how should the internet
social media have been created
differently in the 90s it's a great
question here's a counterfactual
basically his policy and I remembered a
lot of the people who did that we're
studying what happened when the printing
press came off and we're very excited
about it a little bit worried about it
but not worried enough what you're
saying I think if you if you look back
on on the way the printing press
developed there was a for-profit wing
that ultimately did finance itself by
selling ads and it evolved into
newspapers and magazines but that was
only a fraction of all the printed
content that was out there most printed
content was accessible free through
things called libraries and libraries
were nonprofit absolutely ready existed
they'd already exist the public
libraries gradually began to spread in
the protestant realms because remember
process santa's omim sista don literacy
country like mine scotland went from
very low literacy to very high literacy
because of the Reformation schools had
libraries books were regarded as a
public good and this meant that most
printed content was not provided by
profit-making institutions it was
essentially free and crucially catalogs
in increasingly effective and I'll call
them objective ways anybody who spent
time in one of the great libraries of
the world say the Cambridge University
Library knows that the books are sorted
in such a way that you find the book
that you're after and next to it of
books on similar top
this is an incredibly valuable thing if
you're doing serious research Google is
not like that you may think Google is
like that but you're wrong because that
is not how search works so I think when
we look back on the evolution of the
internet the fatal mistake was to have
too much for profit and not enough we'll
call it Wikipedia not enough that was
nonprofit under the printing press by
maintaining a very large nonprofit
sector the network remained distributed
and that was probably the original sin
of the Internet to allow the sale of ads
to be the driver of revenue for
increasingly powerful corporations I'll
say one more thing because it's a great
question
if you look back on the events that led
from the foundation of Amazon to the
dominance of the network platforms in
our time it was a kind of slow burn it
was only really in the last 10 years
that the monopoly capitalism aspect
became apparent so I don't think one can
be too harsh on the people who designed
the internet and the world wide web they
thought it would stay distributed I
think that was Tim berners-lee's vision
the printing press had stayed
distributed even the most powerful
newspaper barons like William Randall
first did not get anywhere close to the
market shares of Facebook and Google
today it's very surprising that we got
to this place and I don't think we can
blame ourselves for not predicting it so
you study economics a lot you did a book
the ascent of money what's your sense of
why unlike with books this kind of very
quick very powerful central deep sort of
resent realization happen what what's
the economic driver of that well there
are two our answers to that question
ones just the classic one that the scale
works
I mean Reid Hoffman has his new book out
masters of scale blitz-scaling I think
the book is called and what that shows
is that the same old thing is true of
Genet companies as was true of motor
companies you know there are returns to
increasing returns to scale but the
other thing which is really powerful
here is quite separate and has to do
with the nature of network platforms the
economics of two-sided markets it turns
out that in the domain of networks that
the power law or the Zips law rather
applies more strongly under Zips law in
a networked market it's a kind of 90% to
the winner 9% to the runner-up and 1%
everybody else outcome and and that
means that we have a double economic
tendency towards concentration again
that wasn't I think well understood and
it's only recently that economists have
begun to see the peculiar quality of
these so-called two-sided markets where
a company like Facebook acts as a
platform in which consumers can connect
with with sellers it looks like it's
free but actually it's anything but free
because the sellers are paying so much
to get the attention of the consumers
all of this I think came as a surprise
to economists who who by and large
lagged behind the development of the
network platforms there very very few
economists Matthew Jackson at Stanford
is an exception who kind of saw the
significance of this and then of course
you had the problem that I refer to
earlier the the problem of the way the
antitrust law had evolved in the United
States the test was just is the consumer
harmed that was the Robert Bork test now
if you ever mention antitrust to the
likes of Jeff Bezos or any of the other
Titans of the valley they laugh because
it'll be so easy to win those cases
under current law you'll just say dude
it's free and the conversations over so
I think for that reason that was never
going to be much pushback even as these
firms developed really very very
dominant positions in different parts of
the market I mean Amazon has a total
monopoly on audiobooks at the moment I
mean it has basically a complete control
the of an increasingly popular market I
mean a bit hands up if you listen to
books rather than read them right that's
a complete monopoly and we actually
don't have the legal tools to stop that
at the moment and I think it'll be
really hard to change Tim who's got a
new book out which is essentially let's
get back to antitrust and it's almost
it's a trendy thing you know that
there's a sort of hipster antitrust
movement you have to grow a goatee beard
to belong to it and wear a beret and I
live in Portland but it's it's gonna be
so hard to achieve that given the way
the courts are set up and I I dare if
that's one reason that I kind of don't
see antitrust as the way to go
another thing that drove scale I think
it exponentially is the one that didn't
people who were making all of that
according to each other was Metcalfe's
law the power of the net goes up as
basically the square of the number of
the nose exactly and so Jeff came along
and said we're gonna lose money for a
long time because our whole functions
get big fast and they get big fast thing
took off and then what it seems like and
China maybe the interesting counter
example is these things scaled up so
fast and so far and so the 2.27 billion
Facebook users mark and it's not gonna
know what every one of them is up to you
not even remotely
well that's and he's complaining about
the signs of his coming he doesn't know
everything going on in the 10,000 people
working for Facebook so scale has this
sort of built in obscurity apparently
and yet you're saying that China isn't
facing that problem well I think that
probably are more than they would like
to admit okay in the sense that when you
spend time in China and and I I I'm a
visiting professor at Tsinghua actually
do most of my teaching there because
they don't really like me teaching at
Stanford so I I go to China and they're
what striking is that one could say very
frank things that are quite critical of
the regime on WeChat at the time last
time I was there there was a lot of
negative meme circulation with respect
as Xi Jinping's
appearance at a military exercise in
Russia so the idea that they have the
whole thing locked down the illusion I
made to 1984 may be a bit misleading
what they can do is they can have
surveillance over what people are doing
how they're spending and what they're
saying and that is a power that none of
the 20th century totalitarians had can
they from that surveillance maintain
their power indefinitely yeah that's
another question and I think history
would lead you to be somewhat skeptical
about the proposition but a highly
centralized system rooted in the mid
twentieth century vision of one-party
rule can coexist with giant online
networks in which there is at least the
appearance of free speech I'm somewhat
more skeptical about the viability of
this of this regime under these
conditions but it's certainly a
different situation from the one that we
find ourselves in today because least
it's clear in China that the the square
is subordinate to the tower whereas here
we are in this strange situation of
collision where there is in fact an
ongoing and I think escalating conflict
between Washington and Silicon Valley
and it's not clear how that is going to
turn out at the moment there's no
question Facebook and Google have
enormous power they dominate the public
sphere and what we've seen in 2016 and I
think we've also seen it this year is
that that's not a stable state of
affairs for democracy because they
really don't take seriously enough the
responsibilities that I believe come
with the kind of power they have
okay so China is pushing ahead with
artificial intelligence very strongly
they're using it for face recognition
among other things and one imagines a
security state like we used to see in
Eastern Europe where there was a large
amount of basically a citizen tree
surveilling other parts of the day and
you know Stasi had this huge operation
they were not able to hire robots to
watch the citizens of those
trees and places like China or the US or
others who come to mind can and so does
this hierarchical potential for very
powerful one-sided surveillance yet
potentially enhanced or a new kind of
level that we haven't seen before what's
clear is that if the surveillance exists
it can even in a democracy be used
conceivably used for political ends
one once it exists even if it's
currently in the hands of private sector
actors you should not assume that it can
never be nationalized and taken over by
the state that's the first observation
the lesson of the twentieth century is
that any corporation can be nationalized
that those sorts of political events are
far from low-probability like AT&T was
well I'm thinking also of the way in
which in even in the recent past we saw
the entire government-sponsored entities
that run the housing industry taken into
what was politely called conservatorship
but they were basically nationalized
during the financial crisis so I think
we need to be worried that we are
simultaneously building that the tools
of the surveillance state in what we
still think of as a free as a free
society this is a big risk to run and
nor is it desirable that those powers
should remain in the hands of more or
less unregulated private actors I mean I
don't feel better that I'm under the
surveillance of big zucker
than under the surveillance of Big
Brother it's it's not really a radically
different state of affairs if my privacy
is gone it's gone and I don't really
have any way of knowing when it will be
that in time of national emergency a
federal government will simply say we
demand access to the data
the Chinese have it we're at war it's a
national emergency and you must comply
one of the lessons of of history is that
no matter how powerful corporations may
appear at their Apogee think Standard
Oil as well as AT&T
they can be with remarkable ease brought
under the control of government
particularly in times of emergency or
simply when the public turns against
them has happened to stand it off so I
think that the point I'm truly trying to
get her in this new paper which the last
slide summarized is that the status quo
in the United States today is not stable
we can't leave things as they are
because the big tech companies have way
too much power and we can't really
account really believe their
protestations that they'll behave better
in the future I think that's an
extremely important point there
certainly don't seem to me sufficient
incentives for them to be better in the
future
when they're business models are
predicated on engagement they have to
show that you're engaged with the
content to justify what they charge the
advertisers and you will be engaged by
the sensational I'm afraid even rational
people like the ones in this audience
will be seduced by the extreme views and
the fake news the business model
inherently favors polarization and I
don't see anything that has changed in
the last two years to alter the
incentive for these companies to promote
in their recommendation lists that which
is sensational so there are some
fundamental things that I don't think
have been fixed and that's what I've
been wrestling with how do you fix those
problems without creating a very
powerful federal regulator which that
which effectively transfers the power to
the state I'm usually described as a
conservative by comparison with most
academics that's probably true but I'm
really a classical liberal I worry more
about individual liberty than I do about
oh I don't know traditional values I my
views are those of the Scottish
enlightenment and what I'm trying to
come up with when I say let's create
greater liabilities for these companies
or essentially ways of constraining them
forcing them to behave themselves better
that don't empower the government and
potentially hand the power of the
surveillance company to the state
question from Sean Jewell basically
relating to your piece of of history
accelerating says so
seems like tech is progressing faster
than our government's ability to
regulate as this novel has happened
previously in history governments is one
of the things that so long as this
layered thing of how commerce moves very
rapidly and governments not necessarily
governments which the nature of
governance is slower than that and and
these kind of debates we're always
saying well that's terrible cuz
governance can't keep up right with what
needs to be governed does that happened
before and what do you ever say about
always that's the standard pattern the
innovation doesn't come from the
hierarchy doesn't come from the
government innovation comes from the
network
that's very clear the industrial
revolution isn't the product of a few
brilliant people who dreamt up the steam
engine the Industrial Revolution happens
because there's a network of people some
academic some just almost self-taught
engineers who together solve a series of
problems that are really worth first
thought of it properly in the scientific
revolution but didn't really get thought
of technologically until the late 18th
century so the network's creative but
here's a really critical difference the
technologies of the Industrial
Revolution that were so important in
propelling the world out of what was
more or less sustained poverty by and
large produced networks with a
hub-and-spoke
architecture think of railroads think of
the Telegraph's
think of the steamship companies so that
Industrial Revolution technologies which
were certain not the creation of the
state lent themselves very readily to
state control as long as you controlled
the hub you controlled the railroad
network you control the telegraph system
so in the nineteenth century what
happens is that private entrepreneurs
beginning in the British Isles invent
railroads of the invent Telegraph's and
they start building them it's it's
entirely done by private enterprise and
within a very short space of time these
technologies are adopted by European
governments and then they're adopted in
North America and they're rolled out and
they are extraordinarily easy to control
centrally the 20th century
regimes that we think of as the
totalitarian regimes beginning with the
Soviet Union understood that with
hub-and-spoke technology he who controls
the hub controls the network
Stalin literally controlled the central
switchboard of the Soviet telephone
network and would routinely as Steve
Cochran shows in his brilliant biography
tap the phones of other members of the
Politburo so I think the difference in
our time is that what happened in the
70s was essentially the pentagon said
look we're kind of busy with the Vietnam
mess could you just kind of do what you
want to do out there with with what was
then ARPANET there was a moment at which
the state basically let go of what was
to become the Internet and the
innovation happened in in a kind of
almost a fit of absence of mind by the
national security state it grew very
rapidly and because of the way that it
was designed it was highly decentralized
I actually have a lovely picture on my
office wall that caught Eric Schmidt's
eye the other days he was passing it of
the original ARPANET which has a kind of
square shape and all the different nodes
are marked on it like Stanford and
Harvard and it was pointing out where he
actually was in the Xerox node there is
one little node down in the bottom right
hand corner that just says Pentagon it's
not in the middle it's not the center of
this kind of hub-and-spoke type of
architecture it's just one node in what
is a distributed network so that's
different in our time here the
technologies raced ahead precisely
because it was designed to be
decentralized and nobody I think
expected it not to stay that way two
questions one from Alex Pico or one from
Kevin Kelly both it basically raising
the question of television and where it
fits in
Arcanine back to 2016 you've got a
counterfactual of what if there was no
social media a similar one would be what
if there was no fox news
the process of polarization let me make
it clear
predates Twitter this was already a
pretty polarized country but even before
the advent of of the internet what the
cable TV revolution did was to end those
regulations that had enforced rules on
political coverage rules that would
require even airtime for rival
candidates and created a new
architecture in which you could have
liberal news and conservative news but I
think what's striking about the last 10
years is the way in which our
pre-existing division and it's a
division not just between liberals and
conservatives there's also this
exhausted middle of people who think of
themselves as independents but this
division has been exacerbated by social
media and it's interesting to watch the
way that the established media not only
TV channels but also newspapers got into
a curious feedback loop with social
media where they would notice that their
social media numbers were boosted by
Trump appearing this is the morning
Joe's story and they would say gee we're
doing really well on Twitter this
morning we should have him back and so
there was this curious symbiosis between
what we think of as mainstream media or
traditional media and and the new media
to the point that the one became
somewhat parasitic on the other so I
think the polarization is not new there
have been other periods in American
history of great division let's not
forget there was an actual civil there
was an actual civil war right now we
just have a kind of virtual one but I
think the social networks have made it
worse and there's lots of good evidence
for that Jonathan Hyde my friend at NYU
whose brilliant book with Greg lukianov
the coddling of the American mind you
should all read he had a great
illustration of this showing the
increase in proportion of people who say
they hate the other party and that
that's something really quite recent so
I do think we're in new territory and
it's not right to say oh it's it's just
what
it's just the way it was because the way
it was in the early days of fox news and
the way it was then on CNN was very
different I mean if one went back now
and looked at the content that those
networks were putting out in the early
days one would be quite startled by how
bland it would seem so networks are
described as these are the three modes
centralized decentralized and so-called
distributed well there's basically not
much in the way of home activity mm-hmm
I was in Prague a couple weeks ago for a
gathering of the etherium blockchain
crowd devic on floor and there was this
groundswell of hopefulness and kind of
joy about the process of developing a
seriously distributed network that can
cut across a lot of things which tend to
keep flying into the hierarchical mode
and toward the end of your book and you
did this book about money after all you
would call attention to Bitcoin and
smart contracts and blockchain in
general where do you see that fitting in
to the story as it comes to pass or
doesn't comes to pass yeah it's a great
question and to all the Bitcoin holders
in the audience and on the platform it's
been a pretty bad time down below 6,000
today I'm Nora
I do neural Rubini is gloating as we
speak he's sought to relaunch his career
as the prophet of the doom of crypto I I
have a less negative view than Nouriel
and I've actually written at great
greater length on this subject in what
will be a new edition of the ascent of
money out early next year with two new
chapters taking the story up to the
present and one of the last chapter is
entitled from the euro to aetherium and
the argument that I make there is that
there's no question that there will be
at least one use case for blockchain a
meaningful use case it's not clear that
it will be money
what we have in Bitcoin I would think of
as an option on digital gold it might
turn out to be something with gold like
qualities that you might if you had a
million dollars want to have one or two
or three percent of your portfolio
my view is that if you want if you have
a million dollars lucky lucky you if you
have a large amount of money and can
afford to have a diversified portfolio
you should if you if you're a regular
professor you probably are a long
real-estate whether you like it or not
because most of your portfolio is that
incredibly expensive house that you had
to buy near the Stanford campus so this
is a sort of recommendation for the high
net worth individuals in the room not
for the regular folk but if you are if
you have a relatively high net worth
let's say north of a million dollars
then you might want to have one or two
percent of it in it's something like
gold something like Bitcoin just because
it behaves differently from the rest of
your portfolio and is unlikely to be
wiped out if the stock market crashes
it'll just behave differently
the problem with Bitcoin and this is a
long conversation I'll try and keep it
short is is a couple of things one while
it might be a cool store of value
remains to be seen or at least an
interesting asset to own it's definitely
not something that you would transact it
so it's not making the cut as money
conventionally understood the other
problem is that even although it was
designed to be decentralized it's funny
how the mining got concentrated super
fast and air in China that definitely
wasn't part of the plan and it's an
illustration of how the best-laid
schemes of distributed network designers
often go a glai as the government well
the interesting thing about the Chinese
government strategy is is that it wants
simultaneously to prevent Bitcoin being
held by Chinese citizens but control the
network fire mining and that's not a
particularly enticing prospect given
that if you have more than 50% of the
mining then you potentially control the
whole
Chane and you can alter it so here's the
way I'm thinking about it now it's not
dead but it's vulnerable and it's
especially vulnerable to state mandated
digital currency here I agree with
something that the neural Rubini just
published it's what I say actually in
the square in the tower that the Chinese
are most likely to create bit you on at
some point they're experimenting with
blockchain based currencies just to see
if they can make it work but they
certainly aren't going to make a non
state controlled digital currency legal
tender in China so the use case for
blockchain probably isn't money it may
very well be that there are uses for
blockchain I know there are some people
in the audience who take a different
view but there may be uses when it comes
to the storage of data in forms that
don't require high frequency of change
title-deeds is the case that most often
gets cited but but I guess the story of
the crypto experiment really is a
chapter in in financial history that
illustrates a point you made earlier
Stewart the way in which innovation runs
ahead of regulation a lot of terrible
analogies were drawn last year with the
tulipmania you may remember that anybody
who didn't understand Bitcoin would say
oh it's tulipmania because it's saved
trying to understand it but it's not
remotely like tulipmania what it is like
is a phase of innovation that produced
the the instrument we call the stock or
equity and that innovation in the early
18th century produced bubbles just as
we've seen in the last 12 months
chaos fraud it's a free-for-all very
similar to the Mississippi bubble and
the South Sea Bubble of the early 18th
century at the end of which the notion
of equity finance survived the really
was a use case for this so I think it
will be somewhat similar here in the end
something will come of it I don't think
it all ends up as zero can it stay it's
say use cases developed for bar chain
apart
crunching as these secured public
Ledger's that really really are
distributed do you see that as some kind
of if if if that develops is that some
kind of Wikipedia like leavening to the
problems you see here potentially one of
the most interesting writers in this
subject lives in these these in this
town Sam lesson whose essays for the
information I found very illuminating
and I think he's one of those blockchain
believers who's attracted by the
technology because it has libertarian
implications decentralized and not
controlled by the state and you'd have
to be a kind of natural-born
authoritarian to want that to fail I
think my instinct is I want this to work
I'd love there to be a use case I
particularly like the idea that some
data will be stored in a decentralized
way we've been dependent on centralized
archives for much much longer than the
printing presses existed one of the
defining functions of a state going back
to the medieval period is that it has an
archive and in that archive truth
resides now in a free society that's
sort of unproblematic we don't really
think twice about the fact that there
are these things called the National
Archives in Washington where you can go
and do historical research as this story
and I depend on those archives and and
frequently use them but you can't as an
historian ignore the fact that very
often the state's central control of
information is abused the archives get
we did and now we're back in the realm
of 1984 the state decides what data are
preserved and what are destroyed so the
idea that some information could be
stored in ways that did not require the
state as the third-party arbiter that
seems attractive and likely to work you
won't be surprised at the internet
archive base here in town which is a
none
seriously non-government entity is very
much in bed with some of the bar chain
folks and they're looking for ways to
enhance each
capability I think as a as a student of
political theory I I sight strongly with
Alexis de Tocqueville's view that
Liberty is dependent on decentralization
it's one of the central arguments in
democracy in America and in the old
regime and the revolution that the
problem in Europe was particularly in
France was excessive centralization and
the great strength of the United States
top fuel saw was its decentralization
well lo and behold we've ended up being
pretty centralized and I think we need
to think of technological ways but also
of good old-fashioned political ways to
be more decentralized that should be a
kind of goal that liberals and
conservatives can agree on that we
should be a little bit more like
Switzerland in our governance and a less
like like France so you as a
conservative it must be interesting
times I think the Liberals haven't
really had to change their worldview
very much but you know the David Brooks
is sort of complaining to the world that
as a conservative feels like he doesn't
have a home anymore there's no political
party you can call his own because of
the what's happened basically with
conservative politics and the last
couple of elections and here in
California Orange County used to be
totally red it was totally Republican
that was totally blue and there's a
super majority of Democrats in our state
legislature and so on are these
interesting times free was definitely a
rude awakening that question
are you or have you ever been a defender
of Donald Trump that'll be the question
asked in the great investigative
inquiries held after Donald Trump's
departure from the White House I mean I
I think as I said I don't really see
myself as a conservative my classical
liberal I rooted in the teachings of the
late 18th century Enlightenment thinkers
and the good news is that late 18th
century ideas turn out to work quite
well the reason the Enlightenment
happens in those places where it happens
is that they'd add the Reformation the
thing about the Reformation is it has
this unintended consequence you teach
people to read so that they can read the
Bible and then they can read anything
it's the great unintended consequence of
the 16th century and in Scotland which
in the initial phase of the Reformation
is basically like Afghanistan under the
Taliban I mean you have this sort of
ultra Calvinist regime in the south of
Scotland and warring tribes in the north
it's a complete Afghanistan situation in
the space of a hundred years because of
literacy it leaves behind these crazy
battles of the Reformation and and
arrives at the ideas of Adam Smith and
David Hume and the rest so that's a kind
of reason for optimism and the ideas of
the Enlightenment spread through a
network I talked about this in the book
the Enlightenment was a network nobody
sat at head office saying what do we do
in the Enlightenment today there's no
chief executive of Enlightenment Inc
it's actually just a bunch I'm really
sorry to say this of white guys there
are some women it's mostly guys writing
to one another publishing stuff
Jefferson is sitting getting his
collection of books shipped over
Franklin to the ideas of the
Enlightenment cross the Atlantic through
the Enlightenment network they go very
global it's remarkable how far say
Voltaire's ideas travel and out of these
ideas comes a design for a republic
which is going to be new in its to new
and innovative in being designed to
avoid tyranny
now the classical theory of politics
said if you have a democracy it'll
become a tyranny that just always
happens that was the standard view right
the way from the ancient Roman Republic
it's the venetian republic iroquois
league they're constantly asking
historical questions about how can we
avoid that happening here and they come
up with the notion of checks and
balances that's central to the way the
constitutions designed it's very
counterintuitive
let's not have power in one institution
let's designers to be a kind of
institutionalized conflict and the good
news is it works Alexander Hamilton
brilliantly foresaw in a number of
speeches and letters that some
opportunistic demagogic figure would be
bound to become president at some point
he explains exactly how it will happen
and the goal of the Constitution is to
make sure that that person cannot
overthrow Liberty because that person's
power will be checked by the other post
Constitution when Trump was elected some
of my best friends including Andrew
Sullivan became overwhelmed with anxiety
that tyranny was about to be established
Tim Snyder at Yale published on tyranny
and my attitude was chill the
Constitution was designed for precisely
this eventualities and if you look at
the results closely at the results of
the midterm as you'll see just how well
it's worked and the founding fathers
must be going
job done checked balanced thank you very
much indeed sir
thank you thank you
[Music]